he has spent 25 seasons as the padres tv
color
analyst the former major league pitcher
mark grant joining us now first pitch
padres dodgers nlds game one
is tonight at 9 30 eastern been a long
time mark
how are you hi how you doing
dance bastard it's been a long time
since the padres have been to the post
season
in fact the last time i watched pottery
baseball when they were so
bad i had a six-pack before the sixth
inning
as sure as god made green apples
the chicago cubs will not be in the
world series
this year how's it going dayton flyer
hi buddy uh dan it's been a it's been a
long time my friend how are you
i'm i'm doing great now while you're
doing your hairy carry
todd fritz has been working on a
drug
[Music]
did you ever meet harry kerry i did um
and it was a treat
i mean i grew up in joliet illinois and
you're
very much familiar with that now
everybody
says you know you're uh a product of
your environment well i believe you're
also a product of your sports
environment
i grew up listening to jack brickhouse
and harry kerry well dan guess what kind
of announcer i'm going to be
if i if i become an announcer right i'm
going to be a homer and you know i'm a
self-proclaimed homer i love my padres
i love the game of baseball i like but
then again you know be
you got to be critical about your team
too and believe me there's been a lot of
that over the years but i love my
i love my friars uh i'm so happy for
them to be in the playoffs this year uh
you got a bobble head over your shoulder
yeah i saw it's a small bobble head
can you guess who it is is it too small
it's too small
okay you want me to bring it up over
here yeah yeah you can bring it up
because i see all your pictures and
everything yeah
yeah you know i don't have a lot of
baseball memorabilia in my house
by the way i'm sporting my slam diego
shirt well you don't you don't have many
baseball memories worth having
you know what uh if somebody's got a
picture of somebody uh
behind third base by the dugout backing
up third that's probably the picture
what what is your favorite baseball
memory like just to give the audience
an idea of the quality of play
you know what i had a one two three
inning back in 1988 i think it was
august 18th and it was a day game at
jack murphy stadium
it was unbelievable it was the most
exciting it was like an eight pitch
inning as well
yeah i snuck a strikeout i got a couple
of couple of ground balls a jam shot
into the first baseman
who how many hall of famers do you think
you struck out in your
career uh one that comes to mind
is uh you know what you have
okay you ask amy pitcher numbers and
they're going to remember numbers
i remember some numbers the one that
really sticks out ozzy smith was 2 for
20 off me
so i mean i struck out ozzy smith
um obviously he was known for his glove
and i think he had a fever that day
maybe
um or the times that i faced but i i
gosh i can't remember dan i know
probably uh your staff there has all
those stats like did you face
bonds did you face mcguire and your face
good question i i faced very uh barry
bonds and he never hit a home run off of
me but he hit like 465.
but you kept him in the ballpark and you
know what he i remember
i was announcing my first five or six
years whatever and barry was with
the giants and i told him hey i i own
you you never hit a home run off me
so so somebody i said i'll bet he goes
i'll bet you a dollar i hit a home run
off you i said okay you're on
so the statistician back then you know
there was no internet so they checked
numbers
no home runs but 465 whatever it was so
he gave me the dollar bill and he signed
it he goes i own you force 35
average no home run so that's that was
pretty cool all right
the padres uh kind of captured people's
imagination here you got a lot of young
talent there i'm curious mark grant the
pitcher
as opposed to mark grant the homer for
the padres
how you would react to tatis
hitting hitting a grand slam and having
a bat flip
um as a pitcher would probably i'll be
quite honest with you if i was out there
pitching it would probably
disrupt my timing it would probably tick
me off no doubt about it
but as i've grown older and balder and
fatter
i think that these unwritten rules
sometimes are kind of just
tear them up throw them away the game
has changed so much dan and you know
that i mean
the entertainment value you know the old
mlb adage
let the kids play i'm all for that i
don't think fernando
or anybody is really showing up a
picture it's the excitement of the game
i mean let's face it the media we have
these days just has
these guys every single moment watching
what they're doing when they're at bat
when they're on the mount or whatever
so in fact we talked about this after
the fact when fernando did that
i said mike my bottom line was you know
what as a pitcher now pitch better
what are we supposed to do three and oh
just hitter's just supposed to lay down
the bat
and then give the hitter a free strike
and then just uh
you know lay it in there give the
picture a free strike now it's three in
one now he makes that
really really good pitch you kind of
take it at the knees okay now it's three
two now what do i do
i'm really protecting roll something
over you know whatever so
my philosophy is bottom line pitch
better make a better pitch 3-0
i love it and i think you have to
attract a whole new generation here
now i don't i don't want it to be
gimmicky but
let's have some i don't know if people i
don't think there's
enough celebrating the game itself and
it feels like
old school hey these are the rules or
the unwritten rules and
i loved what tatis did i think it's
organic i really do and when you look
around baseball dan i think a lot of it
is organic because the guys are
once you get to know these guys too it's
very very important to know that that it
is organic they're not just making this
up
and i want to know where it's written to
where you know times have changed no
doubt about it but i want to know where
it's written that baseball
was a tennis match where it was
a a game to where you're supposed to be
uh proper and you know i'm all about not
showing up the opponents
don't don't get me wrong but showing
emotion i think is a huge part and
you're absolutely right
with this crop of talent that we have
especially i'm speaking for san diego
manny machado fernando tatis jr
the whole shooting match i mean it's a
it's about time to where these guys go
out there and
show some show some emotion and uh you
know when a guy hits a home run and he
backflips and he looks at his teammates
in the dugout and does the old you know
fist pump or whatever the case may be
you know fans love that i love that it's
the emotion of the game and
it should i have no problem with it how
do the padres beat the dodgers
well it's going to have to be well first
of all the pitching is a big question
mark uh
any baseball fan out there who's been
watching the nelson lament mike levinger
uh clevenger hasn't pitched since the
23rd uh there's a chance that he might
get a start
uh lumet hasn't pitched since the 25th
of september
uh so i think the the achilles heel for
the pod raises the starting pitching
there's no question about that
they were six and four against the
dodgers this year how did they beat him
they beat bueller earlier this year they
beat kershaw once this year they're
gonna have to grind out at bats i know
it sounds like a lot of cliches but
these guys are good pitchers let's face
it the dodgers when you look at their
pitchers
when healthy they've got really good
pitchers uh it's going to be tough to
beat
i think one of the games is going to be
possibly a bullpen game for the padres
how about that using nine pitchers in
the game major league record
one of them probably going to be a
slugfest um that you know teams can't
get to kershaw can't get to bueller
but avoid the strikeouts i think that's
one thing dan i remember gosh you talked
about watching bad baseball for many
years my goodness
over the course of some seasons after a
ball game there would be
count them four innings of strikeouts
four innings of padre hitters striking
out
that is not fun to call that is not fun
to watch
did you cry when they clinched a playoff
spot
i got a little emotional yeah i did and
i'll tell you why i'll tell you why
after watching so many well first of all
wearing the padre uniform for three
years
and living here in san diego and having
the the gig that i do have
you know you grow attached to your team
and i was sick and tired
of the dodgers coming into town and
kicking our you know what's around
kicking their you know what's wrong i'm
not on the team but i say hour um i was
sick and tired of the cardinals coming
to town i was saying you get the idea
i was sick and tired of people treating
the padres like the doormat of the
national league
coming in and say oh yeah we'll sweep
them three games they're horrible you
know we'll be in their bullpen in the
third inning which was true i was
sick and tired of it it was it was
accumulation
of everything
more for the fans that have endured such
brutal baseball over the years
uh very lean years to finally have
something to cheer about
and it all of a sudden it just kind of
got to me
and it was like gosh that family in la
mesa that's been following the pottery
since the pcl days
that family in escondido that's been
loving the padres since 1970.
you know where i'm going with this so it
was an accumulation of everything
wearing the uniform
getting their butts kicked and then
finally getting a chance to go to the
postseason since 2006. it's just kind of
all hit me so
and you know if you're watching on
peacock uh mark grant has got
some things in the background there but
you're one of the
first guests now who who is that uh
that is
dwayne kuiper oh the the famous
broadcaster there dwayne kuiper yep
dwayne is probably my dearest friend in
baseball white light-hitting dwayne
kuiper
uh hi dwayne kuiper one home run off of
steve stone has a cleveland idea
i do love that you've got you've got
polk uh like a
pulse uh sticks there but you don't have
a pool table which is is interesting
in your man cave there like that's a
nice little touch that it looks like you
have
a pool table well you know what i do
have a pool table my ipad is propped up
on three pillows right here no it's
okay mark i i understand you look you
you don't have it you don't have it but
i'm sitting i'm actually sitting in old
stadium seats from old comiskey park
back in chicago they remember the green
wooden yeah so anyway that's about the
only thing i have this is the only
baseball thing i have in my house
right here a dwayne kuiper bobblehead
doll yeah the light hitting second
baseman
the captain dwayne kuiper so um
well good luck and have fun thanks you
know
do you remember the last time we hung
out should we talk about it
i could tell you where we were and when
it was okay
1991 atlanta georgia
jackson jills yeah craig sager's bar
huh yeah that's right god rest his soul
yeah craig sager's bar
and we were just yucking it up having a
good time of course that was the year
that the braves went to the world series
in 1991 i was hurt i was the official
cheerleader of the team
i did not pitch one inning that year and
that's why the braves were so successful
so does this count as hanging out and is
this fate
that we're reuniting in this day and age
yes this is hanging out anytime i can
look at my ipad and see i mean you look
great thank you i mean
oh my gosh you still have your hair yeah
yeah you still
you still look um great and i feel bad
because
you know i always enjoyed hanging around
you but there was no reason to have you
on the show because you hadn't done
anything successfully
and and so i mean no offense mark i just
like i couldn't
be on hey another padre season where you
won 68 games
right but i'm happy that we can
reconnect because the padres
the padres are bringing us together yeah
i can um
the only success let's see
i all those bad years i i had some great
food in the press area
i you know i gained a lot of weight yeah
um
ate a lot of yogurt frozen yogurt you
know all those pottery losses
were like tilted uh evenly because there
was a great yogurt machine in the
pressed dining room
that's that's why i loved going to the
padre games back then is because of the
yogurt
the baseball the baseball wasn't so good
but the yogurt
how many losses how many losses have you
been a part of as a broadcaster with the
padres have you totaled it
well i started i started in 1996. uh
this will be my 25th season
and i i would say the teams that were
above
500 were well 90 98 96
1996 was uh
98 2006. there were some good years
there middle 2000 2007
2008 i would gosh maybe fewer than 10.
no the total of losses like the number
of
games that you've watched the padres
lose in twenty
it's gotta be gotta be over a thousand
right
you know what i'll get my stat guy to do
it and
since 1996. and by the way
and have you ever been uh mistaken for
uh the uh steve the
jerry springer bodyguard steve wilkins
steve wilkos
yeah have you ever been mistaken for him
i have never uh no people no i have
never no uncle fester yes
[Laughter]
i can see also a little cal ripken in
you too
very very little no no very fast very
very little very they it's their fat cal
ripken
cal was a better pitcher
i'm being mean-spirited here i never got
to pitch in the shows
that's okay that's the dan patrick i
know of course yeah
uh hey great great to catch up with you
and i'll talk to you in
25 years so let's see 25 years i'll be
40
i'll be 57 this month uh hey
i'll i'll i'll see you uh i'll have my
walker and um i'll have my metamucil
with me and all that good stuff paulie
put it in the rundown
done to call mark grant in 25 years
thank you buddy
damn be well that's mark grant 25
seasons padres
color analyst there